washington journal continues krugman
author of end this depression now he
also writes for The New York Times you
can find his regular column there
joining us from New York City this
morning good morning and thanks for
being with us good morning let's start
with the title of your book in surveys
of economists most say where we are in a
bit of an economic recovery they use the
term recession but you have this
dramatic phrase of depression and this
depression now is the title of your book
why well okay the way I think about it
is a recession is when things are
heading down a depression is when things
are down and we really are way way down
so we have some months when things look
a little bit better in some months when
they don't we basically been moving
sideways pretty much for for a couple of
years now but it's a terrible situation
out there four million almost four
million Americans have been out of work
for more than a year right the RAM 13
million are out of work in total job
opportunities for recent graduates of
college are largely non-existent so this
is a ongoing really bad situation which
is now you know it's been going on for
years has every prospect of continuing
it's not as bad as the Great Depression
you know great campaign slogan not as
bad as the 1930s but it is worse than
anything since the 1930s and I think the
right way to think about it is that this
is a depression it is a long period of
substandard economic performance that's
doing a lot of human damage to this
country you dedicate your book to the
unemployed you say it's to the
unemployed who deserve better why yeah i
think if well because they didn't do
anything wrong first of all you know the
we talked about there's this tendency to
make it a morality play and say oh we
over borrowed we over we had access but
the people who have had jobs they didn't
do that that's not their fault and it's
and it's gratuitous this thing could be
solved very very easily I spent a lot of
time looking at what people were saying
during the 1930s and you heard a lot of
the same things you here now this is
long term we need structural reform its
it can't be solved quickly and then came
to build up not even World War two but
just the increase in government spending
in preparation for World War two and
just like that we were back to full
employment we could do the same thing
right now so this
is this the the bad thinking and
political deadlock among our elite is
keeping millions of millions of
Americans in a state of desperation they
deserve better our guest is Paul Krugman
he is the author of end this depression
now he's the winner of the Nobel Prize
in Economics if you'd like to join the
conversation here are the numbers to
call Democrats 202 737 triple zero one
Republicans 202 737 triple zero two
independent callers 20 to 60 to 80 205 I
have a wall street journal editorial
here reacting to the win of Francois
Hollande in France defeating president
nicolas sarkozy you've had your own
ideas of why this is a interesting turn
of events and a good thing but the Wall
Street Journal looks at it and says that
this is actually a response not calling
for sort of more of freedom and sort of
less of austerity but it says that
Sarkozy and his government just didn't
do it well enough they didn't follow
through well enough his government
responded by raising sales and capitals
gains taxes demonizing successful
frenched businessman complaining that
Germans worked too hard urging an
international financial transactions tax
and trying to pin much of the blame for
economic troubles on immigrants Wow so
it's an amazing thing here we you know
he basically had in pretty much all the
Western world and certainly within
Europe we've had exactly what
conservatives want we've had austerity
programs sharp cuts of government
spending through much of Europe we've
had a really I you know I turn towards
towards trying to have less government
trying to have less support for the
economy which has been a disaster and so
their response as well but you're not
doing it right you know what can you say
I actually don't think that the vote in
France was particularly uh that the
populace had a clear idea of which way
it wants to go but the French public is
saying this this thing we're doing is
not working and we need something
different so as a throw the bums out
which is the right response but you know
it's up to the leaders to come up with
better solutions here and and there is
it as simple as the u.s. tried stimulus
and Europe tried austerity well we
didn't do
whole lot of stimulus when all was said
and done and by the way this is not
hindsight this is not you know if you
were reading my columns in early 2009
the beginning of the Obama
administration I was tearing my hair out
very publicly because this was not an
adequate program and i said if this is
going to look like a failure and people
are going to feel that the whole idea of
stimulus is discredited when we actually
really never tried it but and we've had
quite a lot of austerity if you look at
the cutbacks at the state and local
level there there our own version of
european-style austerity that said the
Europeans have done it on a much more
aggressive scale and they and and the
results are clear I mean if you had any
question about whether cutting
government spending actually is bad for
the economy when it's already depressed
that your question has been answered
just look at just look at the experience
of those austerity countries in Europe
and it's been a dramatic you know we've
just carried out what amounted to a
massive i would say unethical human
experiment on economic policies in
unreal populations and we just found out
which economic doctrines don't work and
the answer is austerity doesn't let's go
to louisville kentucky where john joins
us on the democrats line good morning
good morning not comment I hear
Republicans just like the guy goes on
before you were talking about rising
medical costs and I used to be a
republic as a matter of fact I ran into
Mitch McConnell couple weeks ago he said
why'd you switch parties I said well you
know I talk about the social issues but
Republicans never did a darn thing to
try to control health care costs I think
health care costs are absolutely destroy
the country not to mention the fact that
Americans are taken care of their health
but you know you go to hospital now what
is a hundred thousand dollars for four
or five days and yeah you know I know
the president tried to tackle it it
wasn't handled real well but yeah my
brother for example his insurance goes
up every year everybody's insurance
keeps going up in the thing with the
Republicans you know that they preach
just like the gown before you you know
is talking about gas prices well the
Republicans do they want to continue oil
subsidies I mean but the my question is
what can be done on these health care
costs I don't see anything happening to
tell you the truth because I don't think
both sides in there
come together if anything I think it's
going to get more partisan and but I
just think that health care costs are
absolutely and destroy this economy well
that looked health is a health care
costs for a tough issue and they're also
a long run issues so I mean the first
thing to do is get an economic recovery
right so with first thing we need to do
is give this economy that the help it
needs to give the private sector the
breathing space in the form of the
support from the government temporarily
so we can get back to full employment
that will do a lot but health care costs
or an ongoing issue on the interesting
thing about the Republican position
there is that they are absolutely
dedicated to the proposition that the
only answer is something that has never
worked anywhere which is rely on private
insurance markets private insurance has
has never been a successful way of
controlling a health care costs anywhere
public health care you know various
there are lots of different ways to do
health care there there's a Swiss
version there's a French version there's
a British version all of them actually
do a much better job of containing costs
than ours does at as far as we can tell
no cost in the overall quality do some
things better something's worse so
that's and look the president's health
care plan it's a Rube Goldberg device he
threw together a bunch of stuff because
for political reasons you have to keep
the private insurance companies in the
mix but it's a really good start I mean
from that positions once we've got it
the principal down there that it
everybody is guaranteed health coverage
and that containing health care cost is
going to be done by containing costs and
not by just throwing more people into
into the abyss and into lack of
insurance that's the right way to go
different question of course this book
you know I have a book now which is i
can write lots and lots and i have about
those issues but but right now i'm
trying to say that the immediate
priority is to get those unemployed
americans back to work in your book you
have a section looking at deficits and
the concern focus on reducing the debt
bringing down the deficit and you call
it the folly of a short-term deficit
focus so give us the difference between
like a long-term focus on Deficit
Reduction versus a short-term focus and
and how the conversation in your
perspective has really shifted and put
the democrats on defense so that the
conversation is totally changed from
stimulus to deficit reduction
yeah so what happened so the you know
the Greeks have got a lot to answer for
because the the Greek disaster made
everybody think they were all about to
turn it degrees which is actually wrong
Greece as a even even among the
Europeans Greece is unique and having
actually been fiscally irresponsible
during the good years the others were
not they were just caught up in a market
crisis sorry by switch to talking about
deficits and it's it's a terrific
mistake for a couple of reasons one is
that now when the economy is depressed
is not the time that you want to be
cutting spending because that depresses
the economy even further wait until the
economy until the private sector is paid
down some of the dead it ran up during
the bat during the bubble is stronger
then you can cut government spending and
the private sector can can take up the
slack but not now so I'm all for
worrying about if worrying about us debt
worrying about the US budget for 10
years for now that by all means we
should have a plan if we can agree on
one which is a problem but we should
have a plan to control our budget over
the next 10 20 30 years but not now not
now is not the time to cut spending and
turns out it's pretty much overwhelming
evidence right now that cutting spending
right now which is what the you know
what the Republicans want to do a fair
number of Democrats is it is a losing
strategy even if the only concern you
have is with the budget because if you
cut spending it depresses the economy
further which reduces reduces revenues
and it also does lots of long-term
damage we've got four million people
who've been out of work for more than a
year as that goes on more and more those
people are never going to be employed
again we've got college graduates unable
to find jobs or if they can find jobs
their jobs that make no use of their
education they're never going to get
back on track those people are the
future taxpayers of America so by doing
these ill-advised spending cuts now not
only are we making the economy worse
we're actually reducing future revenue
we're making the long run budget picture
probably worse instead of better so
anyone who says all it's about the
long-term not short-term this stuff that
we're doing right now is hurting us in
the long term as well as the short term
it's just a let the example I use in the
Middle Ages doctors thought that you
could cure people sick people by
bleeding them
and when they bled them of course they
got sicker and they said well that means
even more bleeding that's exactly what
we're doing in terms of our fiscal
policy right now Paul Krugman author of
end this depression now let's go to
Darrell Louisiana and hear from Scott
independent line oh yes good morning I'm
actually a member of the human party you
know that's the greatest party out there
but uh there's a couple simple
historical scientific things that we
could do to totally turn around our
economy right now the very first diesel
motor the very first diesel that was
designed to run mr. diesel made it to
run off of hemp oil hemp oil no it costs
five dollars a gallon to produce a
gallon of empty so which we could go and
put in our diesel motors today with do
it no modification if we were to take
one step further and go with a marijuana
plant which produces five times the seed
that has does we could go at a dollar
ideal and a diesel well I that's a boy
used to have chicken in every pot now I
guess it's pot in every engine anyway no
it's fine not look I mean lots of things
we should be trying lots of stuff we
should but you know one thing I try to
say in this depression now is that in a
lot of ways the question of how to how
to boost the economy is easier now than
it was three years ago when President
Obama was new in office then you have to
have one of the projects what are we
going to spend on now we've had this
severe cutbacks at the state and local
level we've laid off hundreds of
thousands of school teachers
firefighters policemen we can we
deferred maintenance you look at my I
live in New Jersey there's potholes
everywhere because of deferred
maintenance just by restarting that by
providing the federal funds that will
allow the states and localities to go
back to doing their normal business you
can give an economy a really large boost
doesn't require anything innovative
doesn't require anything speculative you
know by all means let's push for
alternative energy all kinds of things
but first and foremost put those school
teachers back to work good for our
education good for our children and good
for the economy give us that boost we
need to get back to a decent job market
c-span junkie asks on Twitter where the
US money should
from the pay for teachers and firemen
c-span junkie asks raising real estate
taxes what's your what's your idea Paul
Krugman know right now you just borrow
it because the fact of the matter I when
you're facing a human when you have a
really good investment opportunity if
somebody is willing to lend you money
cheap you should take that so right now
investing in boosting this economy is a
really good investment opportunity and
the US government can borrow money
really cheaply I mean it's a markets are
willing to lend you know 10-year bonds
at under one point nine percent you can
sell the US government sell bonds that
are protect against inflation those have
got a negative interest rate right so
money is available the long run we're
gonna have to pay regardless it had the
amount of money we spend right now it
makes almost no difference to the long
run budget picture we are going to need
some combination of spending cuts
additional taxes later and we can talk
about that I'm I'm you know I I think we
need to do health care costs we need to
find some additional revenue sources but
that's not the issue right now right now
the money that the markets are sort of
saying please here's our money take it
use it for something useful and we can
do that Brooklyn New York honey says a
democratic caller good morning on good
morning peace be upon you thank you for
a seat man it's an honor to speak to mr.
Krugman been following him for years I'd
like to know how what he feels about the
Tobin tax which was an idea that was
generated by an American of Irish
descent about taxing everything that was
a small tax that is dividends you know a
stock up on we used to have a stock
transfer tax in New York City that
Giuliani to go up and I feel about you
know these big corporations they have
plenty of representation and no taxation
and the rest of us are paying taxes they
pay nothing when they buy and sell
stocks and there's an enormous volume
Cameron of the UK the PM he said that he
would support the Tobin tax idea if it
was universal because people who do you
know business with those who buy and
sell stocks would move to someplace
where there was no tax
for the benefit their customer sorry
this is a big company so that it is so
the idea is to have a small tax on
transactions that take place in foreign
exchange markets stock markets whatever
very small you know fraction of a
fraction of a cent it's it which would
serve two purposes it would generate
revenue and it would somewhat
discouraged hot money people from doing
high-speed you know jumping in and out
of stuff which can be destabilizing I
don't think that hot money is the core
of what went wrong with our economy I
think it was actually longer-term bad
bad decisions it was it was bad
mortgages not bad you know three month
or even you know one day investments but
still part of the issue and the money
could be useful so I'm all for it and
yes it does need to be that the two
great financial centers of the world are
in London in New York and either one of
those is reluctant to move on such
things by itself because the business
will move to the other so so we in the
British to get together and do this I
mean we have we can even speak the same
language more or less so we should be
able to coordinate on on this useful
it's not panacea but it's a useful thing
looking at a headline from The Guardian
this week austerity backlash sends euro
back to the danger zone and it has a
picture of germany's chancellor angela
merkel looking in the picture a little
bit frustrated like Oh what should we do
now sorta look Monty writes on Twitter
and asks what are the consequences for
our recovery from a possible collapse of
the euro maybe you could just address
the the big picture for the US economy
sure so okay you need a little
perspective so there's two ways there's
two kinds of pro of threats one thread
is massive financial collapse a sort of
super version of the failure of Lehman
in 2008 that can be devastating
everywhere just as the failure of Lehman
you know sent the whole world into a
slump something like that in Europe
could have the same effect I think
that's not too likely because the
European Central Bank and the Federal
Reserve sort of saw what happened last
time they're standing there they have
essentially unlimited funds to throw at
this because they print money
so I think that's that's controllable as
for the rest it's not as bad as people
think I mean the European situation is
awful and I'm I'm and and we should be
deeply concerned about that but
primarily because Europe is is our ally
Europe is is the other great Democratic
entity in the world not the only one but
Europe in the United States are the two
pillars of a democratic peaceful world
so if things go bad in Europe that's bad
for that's bad for everyone and
certainly bad for us the direct economic
impact is less than people think because
when you actually look how much stuff do
we actually sell to Europe it's not
trivial it's but it's only about two
percent of what we produce so even if we
take a pretty serious hit to our exports
to Europe it's not going to be a huge
blow to the US economy so I think I'm
worried always about our economy and
there are a number of things to worry
about but I'm mostly worried about a
European break up because of what it
means for Europe and what it means for
the future of the world not for what it
means for the US economy next quarter
and touching on that one of our other
tweeters writes in and asks if austerity
has worked anywhere do you see places
where austerity has been successful no
it's a it's a most amazing thing people
want it to work they want to believe it
works and so they keep on promoting
supposed to success stories so that the
poor Irish have been told that they were
a success story not once but twice
summer of 2010 and then again the fall
of last year sure enough it didn't turn
out to be true they're not recovering
there is their economy is still a mess
latvia weird things young people find
some country out there latvia is
supposed to be a success story is true
that they're growing but that's after
having a full great depression level
slump and there's still you know down by
double digits from where they were
before the crisis so their hat you know
people go back through history and they
look for supposed examples of success
for austerity but they all turn out to
have circumstances that don't apply
right now countries that have their own
currencies were able to devalue
countries that had high interest rates
high market interest rates not just not
the kind of risk premium we're seeing
right now and so the answer is no at the
moment there are no success stories not
even by the way say well we have to have
austerity satisfy the
bond markets that hasn't worked either
the Irish have done everything they were
supposed to do and they still can't
borrow on the open market Jim joins us
from Claremore Oklahoma Republican line
good morning yeah I think the problem is
right now we are in true capitalism were
in effect capitalism we should look
instead of looking at the Kensi in
theory we should look at the Austrian
economical theory and we don't have to
capitalism I said I'm sorry and uh as
far as your comment about the Fed the
Fed has no money they print it and the
answer is that keeps taxing people and
or forcing me to have Medicare fair to
buy something they don't okay want yeah
well leave it there and get a response
from Paul Krugman yeah yeah so one you
know if this isn't true capitalism fine
it's like it's like the people who
always said don't don't look at what was
going on the Soviet Union because it
wasn't true communism and we have the
same system we've had basically for
since World War two we've had a
government that provides a safety net we
have some regulation with that system
worked pretty well for a long long time
you know the you know it's not it's not
as if this is some untried experiment
and we're just discovering that doesn't
work we've had 60 plus years of of this
system so this isn't true capitalism you
know if you want to believe in some
imaginary perfect world that has never
existed and that we we can't recover
until we go there fine Austrians I mean
it's just let's just say that we've had
a pretty strong test of different views
as one view that said that that all this
that running government deficits even in
the Depression was going to send
interest rates skyrocketing that hasn't
happened it also said that the fed by
trying to expand you know printing
printing money it doesn't really do that
but call it that was going to lead to
hyperinflation lots of predictions out
there for an Austrians about
hyperinflation by 2012 that hasn't
happened predictions that austerity
they're cutting back on government
spending was going to be expansion ery
because it was an approved improved
confidence take a look at Europe that
hasn't happened so you know what more
can you ask for we've had as as close to
a set of experiments in different
economic doctrines these past three
years as anyone can really ask for and
and basically a Keynesian view has has
people went with the Keynesian view have
been right about all of the major
stories these past three years Paul
Krugman has a recent column in The New
York Times called earth to ben bernanke
let's talk about this for a moment since
our last Oklahoman caller brought up the
fed you write in your book that you
don't think the Chairman's learn from
the Great Depression and you say he was
assimilated by the Fed Borg let's take a
listen to response that that the Federal
Reserve Chairman had this is responding
to critics who say that the Fed should
seek a higher inflation rate to achieve
lower unemployment the view of the
committee is that that would be very
reckless we have we the Federal Reserve
have spent 30 years building up
credibility for low and stable inflation
which has proved extremely valuable in
that we've been able to take strong
accommodative actions in the last four
or five years to support the economy
without leading to a unang curring of
inflation expectations or a
destabilization of inflation to risk
that asset for what I think would be
quite tentative and perhaps doubtful
gains on the real side would be I think
unwise thing to do what's your response
Paul Krugman okay so the first thing is
among those critics who called for
higher inflation in times like these was
a guy by the name of Ben Bernanke who
who was very critical of the Bank of
Japan ten years ago for following pretty
much the same course that the Federal
Reserve is following right now it's it I
mean it it's central bankers speak they
love to talk about credibility and I
understand there's some concerns there
but I think you have to put what I
believe are the quite small risks of
taking some more aggressive action
remember we're not talking about
hyperinflation we're talking about a
target of three or four percent
inflation which is about what the
inflation rate was during Ronald
Reagan's second term in office versus
the not risk but the reality of
destructive extremely high unemployment
I mean every month that this goes by we
are losing more people who will never
get back into the workforce every month
that this goes by more American families
are being torn apart by suffering from
high unemployment I think it's incumbent
on the Fed to take some risks to its
precious credibility in an attempt to
rescue Americans from this I don't think
the Fed can do it on its own but it is
one of the institutions that has some
freedom of action and as I've said in
that article it's I wish that Chairman
Bernanke would reread what Professor
Bernanke had to say on exactly this
subject because I believed in his
academic years he had it right and he's
become too much of a central banker in
his current role can you explain a
little more the culture of groupthink
that you think exists that mr. Bernanke
might be facing okay it's you know
there's a speculation this at this point
we don't know and you know I I like to
imagine that somewhere in a locked
drawer he's got a notebook in which he
writes the truth is I actually believe I
think that that Mike Woodford and and
lars svenson and Paul Krugman you know
all the economist have been arguing
urging him to do more that they actually
have it right we know it was I thought
the phrasing was kind of injury who said
the view of the committee didn't say
start by saying in my view he said the
view of the committee but uh look the
Fed if you're the Fed what do you like
better just just thinking about the
institutional imperative here do you
like the idea that it's your job to
cause an economic recovery or do you
like the notion that your job is to do
what is considered to be responsible for
the Fed to do and as long as you've done
that well whatever happens the economy
not our fault they view that he's
expressing there is one that makes life
much much easier for the institution and
I think what has happened is that he and
the people around him have have ended up
putting priority over making life easy
for the Fed which is not their job
they're not there to have an easy life
there Jared they're there to their
mandate says price stability but also
full employment and they should be there
they should be worrying about why
they're failing so badly on the full
employment bit Paul Krugman Nobel
prize-winning economist at Princeton
University he's also a new york times
columnist and author of the new book end
this depression now Frank joins us from
beach on our independent line go ahead
Frank yes uh thank you mr. krugman I'm
you've been around for a long time and
there's been plenty of times don't
remind me back in the early nineties
where you could have come out and said
folks this is not going to end good with
all of the ridiculous manipulation 24
manipulation of the markets using
artificial monetary and fiscal tinkering
uh to manipulate things uh uh you know
there's you've had him plenty of
opportunities to say hold it we can you
know continue to Eze Eze Eze and
stimulate stimulate I mean a 5th grader
can be trained to uh to just you know
add stimulus to the economy um the
problem is we don't have any real
economist in Washington uh they you know
there's no intellect left in Washington
though there's no academics you know
they've traded their intellect for a
security blanket and a pacifier let's
just be clear when when george w bush
pushed for unfunded tax cuts I said
don't do this this is the time the
economy is reasonably strong this is the
time to to be paying down federal debt I
was really very strong against that when
he called for unfunded Wars I said don't
do this we we're not supposed to be
running up debt just just for a war that
is a war of choice and at a time when
when the economy is is not in need of
stimulus so this is you know this is all
wrong I was actually somebody who was
very much against irresponsible
budgeting unfortunately that was what we
did now with the economy deeply
depressed now is the time when you do
need to spend so there are you know the
appropriate policy depends upon
situations and we are in a very
different situation right now so I just
don't buy the premise I mean it's not
true about me and it's not true you know
if you want to say that we've had
artificial stimulus all these years
again we've got you know it's been the
world war two is 67 years ago and most
of that period we had an economy that
did very well did well with quite a lot
of active policy by both the Federal
Reserve and the federal government so
the question if you think that's an
unsustainable policy
wow you know I locked that's that's
that's a pretty long run it's only the
the missteps we've made in the past few
years that of the real disaster Ron asks
by email from Colorado at what level of
debt do you become concern that the US
will no longer be able to borrow money
countries advanced countries with stable
governments and their own currencies
have got a lot of leeway on its we look
so I there was an interesting thing wet
when we people we've had these debates
and some people just said well you know
John Maynard Keynes may have said
government spending is is the answer but
back in the 1930s governments didn't
have the kind of debt levels that they
have now turns out that Britain at the
time that Keynes was writing and he was
British I had a substantially higher
level of debt relative to GDP than we
have right now advanced countries can
run 120 130 hundred forty percent it's
not good but it's not catastrophic Japan
it's two hundred percent and Japan
people have been predicting a Japanese
debt crisis for as long as i can
remember basically for about a dozen
years and they've lost enormous amounts
of money by doing so because the fact of
the matter is that Japan is still a
stable advanced country with the ability
to raise taxes and its own currency and
they're able to borrow at less than one
percent interest rates so I don't know
where that red line is but all you
evidence suggests it's a long ways up
from where we are right now now is not
the time to obsess about that debt level
sorry and go back to the point I made at
the beginning slashing spending right
now does not actually improve the
situation even if you are worried about
debt levels slashing spending now is
actually going to make things worse it's
it's what you know you say I'm terribly
afraid of the level of debt but if
you're going to do a policy in because
of that that actually makes the debt
situation worse you're not helping the
situation Paul Krugman someone else
written by email done from Las Cruces
and says that you know we just heard
from a Republican congressman mr.
Huelskamp of Kansas he asks what's your
impression of what the congressman said
but let's take it a step further the
congressman talked about concern he's
hearing in town halls back home where
people are really afraid of the debt and
are concerned about the next generation
where did that fear come from
we're hearing from you don't worry about
it so much right now where is America
getting this terror of the debt is it
because of what we're seeing in Europe
where does it come from no a lot of it
is because it's actually it's the
beltway echo chamber people inside
Washington started obsessing or talking
about the die thing a lot of the people
who talk most about the debt really
don't care about it at all they're just
using it as a as a stick with which to
beat the president but but but there's
all this talk about debt from Washington
some of it comes from people who've made
a career out of a warning ominously
about the debt I mean that just you know
not not I have a particular grudge but
trace a lot of the organizations who are
seriously warning about debt and you'll
find that that the funding goes back to
a couple of guys Pete Peterson in
particular the other thing is you can
look at polls from the 1930s okay I have
done that you look at polls from 1936
lots of people then said oh President
Roosevelt should cut spending I'm
worried about the debt and in 1937 he
did just that sent the US economy into a
tailspin that there was a the economy
had a pretty good recovery from 33 to 37
then went downhill again because he
started fiscal austerity too soon so the
fact that that the public has got a view
which is largely conditioned by what
they read in the newspapers and what
they hear from people like the
congressman is you know that's not that
that's not guide for what we should be
doing in terms of actual policy Jackie
and Santa Clara California Democrats
line go ahead good morning woody and
Paul I watched you last night on MSNBC
and I have a couple comments and a
question the Clinton left the third plus
which I think should have been used to
pay back Social Security we had the
first Bush cuts or I think I got five
hundred dollars and the rich people got
thousands of dollars and the second Bush
cut the Iraq war the Afghan war my
question is if those things had not
happened and Obama had not inherited all
of the
problems from the bush is there any way
to judge where our economy would be
right now yeah I have a pretty strong I
mean it's not gonna be quite what you
want to hear I think we would have had
the crash we would be be be in this
depression even if we hadn't had those
bush tax cuts on the wars the the this
thing was building was it was actually
30 years of financial deregulation and a
general sense of complacency that set
the stage for this people forgot that
how bad the economy can get and so they
got careless that includes politicians
so we we took away the safeguards that
have been put up in the 1930s and sure
enough we managed to reproduce the
experience of the Great Depression
fortunately a somewhat smaller scale
what is true about the bush policies is
that first of all some of the financial
deregulation some of the relaxation of
rules took place under Bush they there
were some attempts serious attempts by
state attorneys general to reduce on the
US subprime abuses and the Bush
administration stopped those cold so the
the financial crisis wouldn't have been
quite so bad but the most proximate
thing is without those unfunded wars
without those tax because the u.s. debt
right now would be around three trillion
dollars less than it is and I think
people would do a lot more relaxed about
spending the money we need to spend to
make the economy recover if we didn't
have those three trillion dollars of
extra debt I'd like to see you know I
think we have to do that spending anyway
but boy you know we we did exactly what
you shouldn't do we ran deficits during
the good years the good years are the
times in fact when you do want to pay
down debt and that's that's you know i'm
i'm all for being fiscally responsible
when the economy is strong enough to
stand it and the result was we came into
this bad period with a with a debt
number that looks big it's it's still
manageable but I wish it were smaller
mais Mississippi Clyde is Republican
caller good morning Clyde good morning
mr. Krugman and Libya I want to continue
the conversation you had with dr. Pearle
the other day you this is a quote from
John Maynard Keynes in 1920 by
continuous process of inflow
gomez can confiscate secretly and
unobserved an important part of the
world to their citizens the process
engages all of the hidden forces of an
economic law on the side of destruction
and it does it in a manner that note
that not one man in a million can
diagnose let me yeah breakfast let me
client why do you think that's
significant weary why are you sharing
that with us my finger year in 1971 I
plenty one acre tomatoes and I gross
three thousand dollars off the laker
that was won a silver dollar and a paper
dollar same value well yesterday still
were closed about thirty dollars an
ounce today I grew that same maker
tomatoes to have the same person how I
would have to have 80 8245 paper Federal
Reserve notes and two years ago fell
government so my farm in home not far
for 30 years and I did what Keynesianism
has destroyed our country if you want to
end this depression you give farmers
parity we have had we have been
producing crops and livestock since 1986
below 1932 error levels and that is the
problem that's the way you enter
depression okay once there's way too
much to unpack there but let me just say
on hyperinflation real situations where
governments are trying to pay their
bills by printing money and prices go
through the roof are a bad thing you
know sort of obviously that's what
Keynes was writing about because there
were some real hyperinflation is just
after World War one that is not what
we're going through that is not what has
happened at any point in in in US
history it's just it's just not it's
just not the story it's a completely
different animal and by all means I've
got no brief for further Mugabe regime
in zimbabwe write it this is not my this
is not the point we're talking about
instead policies to provide full
employment
and again we had I I don't know what
people talk a lot about inflation they
obsess about inflation they talk about
the stories of inflation I always think
it's kind of interesting that the
Germans talked endlessly about the 1923
inflation which was indeed a terrible
thing but they don't talk about the 1932
1932 deflation created because
Chancellor bruning insisted on sticking
with the gold standard and a very bad
time to do that and it was actually that
deflation not the inflation that paved
the way for you now who to take power so
you know policies the right policy
depends on circumstances this is not the
time to be worrying about hyperinflation
this is the time to be worrying about a
deeply depressed economy which does call
for printing some money and we're a
little bit of inflation can actually
help history has shown in many cases
that that's true and that's true again
right now Paul Krugman has a new book
out called end this depression now as
part of our social media outreach here
in the Washington journal we are using a
new medium called tout it's a short
video clip let's take a listen to one of
the touts that came in with a question
for Paul Krugman's Paul you describe our
current economic situation is a chronic
condition I believe you're correct I
believe is a chronic condition of
spending beyond our means the answer for
me as an individual would be to cut my
spending and arrays my income preferably
through hard work what do you see the
answers are for our country okay this is
actually this gets to the heart of the
issue because a country is not an
individual country what the crucial
thing to understand anyway the whole
essence of what macroeconomics is about
the essence of how it is we can have a
depression is that my spending is your
income and your spending as my income
and while if I cut my spending I can be
in better shape if I just do it by
myself if I cut my spending and you cut
your spending then what happens is is
that both of us end up poor because
we've you know we've ended up with with
less income and whatever we gained with
the spending cuts are more than made up
for by the loss of income right now we
have a situation where a large part of
America for for good reasons is being
forced to spend less households ran up
too much debt during the
prices if that's all that happens
there's all that you have is the lot of
players in the economy are cutting
spending and nobody is increasing
spending then you get a depression then
you get an economy in which everyone is
worse off now is the time for the
federal government to act as the
flywheel the stabilizer to do the
opposite of what the private sector is
doing if the private sector won't spend
for now the government needs to needs to
act as the spender of last resort so
it's and think of also about the
countries that have practiced austerity
now think about Greece or Ireland you
can say well people ought you know in
trouble should spend less but should
they also work less they should work
more right but what's actually happening
in countries that are trying these
austerity is that their first way of
dealing with spending beyond their means
is to drastically reduce their income by
sending themselves into into severe
economic slump that can't be right and
so they were my everything that what I'm
saying but basically what what any sort
of reasonable economic analysis says is
we have to find a way to keep people
employed we have to find a way to have
this economy produce if you try and
think of it in terms of a household
budget you're going to be led into a
disastrous set of policy decisions let's
hear from an independent caller in
Loveland Colorado charlie is up next go
ahead good morning mr. Krugman it's an
honor to talk with you and we need some
common sense and just a comment please
get off mb MSNBC and get on the fox news
those guys need to get something
straight over there but could you
explain the man I don't like I don't
like talking on T I don't like talking
on TV shows where they cut off my mic
we've been winning the arguments sorry
okay hello go ahead Charlie keep going
oh hi yeah god but can you explain as
American people economic base
multipliers they don't understand that
dollars that are put into the economy
generate up to a dollar 75 and how that
kind of thing works I mean that goes
right to your spending and you also
explain when I look at when our country
is doing the best economically our tax
rates are around 38 to fifty percent and
when our country is doing the worst
economically it's
when we're at the lower tax rate levels
because there is at the spending the
economic multipliers this driving the
economy so when I listen to the tea
party people say let's cut government
let's kill it all we're just cutting off
our nose to spite our face okay so let
me see if I can keep these two things so
um actually the multiplier is it's
actually think about what I think we
should be doing right now what I think I
know we should be doing right now which
is to be rehiring those schoolteachers
rehiring those policemen those
firefighters they would that would
directly be employing those people
because those are real jobs anybody
thinks that teaching teaching under Tino
to teach teaching first grade is not a
real job has never actually tried to
teach young kids but also that would put
more money in the pockets of people of
school teachers of firefighters who
would then spend on other things would
mean more jobs in retail and ultimately
more jobs and us factories so a dollar
put into the economy at a time like this
when the economy is operating with lots
and lots of unemployment actually
generates additional spending it's not
just the the direct employment from the
spending but the indirect effects as it
goes down the chain so that's the
multiplier on it's probably around one a
dollar fifty right now we think that's
but that's certainly part of the story
about tax rates yeah I suppose that I
proposed that we go to an America where
tax rates on the rich were much much
higher than they are now seventy percent
eighty percent and a and we're also
where the minimum wage was way higher
than it is right now relative to the
average earnings and and and which
unions were much more powerful and we
are where they were a third of the
workforce and a lot of people now would
say oh that's a disaster that would be a
collapsing economy I've just described
America in the 1950s America in the
1950s had higher taxes at the top it had
much stronger protections for workers
than we have now it also experienced the
best generation of economic growth that
we've ever had in this country so a lot
of what goes on right now the the what
people think is the truth is actually
prejudices that have been carefully
cultivated by a decades-long propaganda
campaign none of the things you're
hearing about what it takes to make this
country prosper our troop it's it's we
actually have the demonstration that
says that what you really need is you
need good education you need good
infrastructure try and imagine doing the
interstate highway system today and
that's what leads to an a successful
economy upper sandusky ohio deborah
joins us Democrats line good morning
Deborah good morning I just want to say
I agree with everything you say mr.
Krugman and I I mean we were lucky once
we pay our taxes but by god when we want
the police or the fire department here
we want them here but the way things are
going but our governor cases going to
get rid of everything and I just want to
thank you very much for your book yes
and can I say as a resident of New
Jersey who goes into New York quite a
lot I am seriously annoyed at governor
yells at people who cancelled the
proposal the the well-developed plan to
put a second rail tunnel under the
Hudson River where the world's greatest
city is linked to to my state by a
hundred year old tunnel that is running
at one hundred percent of capacity it's
amazing what whatever happened to the
country that used to think about the
future and finally the House Republicans
are talking about getting out of
sequestration by cutting social programs
and holding steady on defense spending
what do you think about the threat of
sequestration doesn't need to stay in
place doesn't need to happen well I mean
know it we shouldn't be doing any of
this right we shouldn't be now is not
the time for spending cuts this is this
is a mistake I'm I think the president
made a big mistake by thinking he could
deal in good faith with the Republicans
and I'd like the whole thing to just go
away because this is not the time it is
kind of amazing that they are prepared
to defend you know any claims that they
really are care about efficiency in
government if there's one area of the
government that has a lot of clear waste
it is defense spending and in order to
avoid doing anything about trying to
control those costs they're willing to
inflict enormous human suffering
on the most vulnerable members of our
society I think that's telling you
something about where their values are
Paul Krugman columnist for The New York
Times author of the new book and this
depression now he's also a Nobel Prize
winning professor of economics at
Princeton University thanks so much for
joining us from New York this morning
thank you coming up next our spotlight
on magazines series we'll take a look at
harper's magazine may 2012 edition a
story about the evolution of public
housing first this news update from
c-span radio it's 920 a.m. eastern time
while picking up on mr. krugman's
comments about defense spending the
house armed services committee meets
this morning to work on a version of the
2013 Defense Department budget that adds
billions to the president's proposed
budget and rejects the administration's
call for military base closings the
spending blueprint calls for a base
defense budget of 5554 billion dollars
plus 88 billion for the war in
Afghanistan and related counterterrorism
efforts that compares what the
administration's proposed figures of 550
1 billion plus that 88 billion you can
watch that markup session live at ten
a.m. eastern time on c-span three
television it's expected to go past 10
p.m. eastern and today at the White
House the president hosts nATO Secretary
General Anders Fogh Rasmussen the two
leaders will discuss final preparations
for the upcoming NATO summit the
president will be hosting that meeting
in Chicago May twentieth and
twenty-first and some more economic news
US mortgage giant Fannie Mae says it
made money in the first three months of
the year and is not seeking additional
federal aid it's the first time the
company has reported a net income gained
since it was taken over by the
government during the financial crisis
the company says the improvement was due
to slower home price declines reduced
inventory of single-family homes and
fewer mortgages in serious delinquency
Fannie Mae has received about one
hundred sixteen billion dollars so far
from the Treasury Department that's the
most expensive bail out of a single
company and those are some of the latest
headlines on season